professor Kuzmich welcome to Yale thank
you for taking the time to talk to us in
conjunction with the course on faith and
globalization and broader Yale
Initiative a concerning faith in
globalization you have just arrived from
the Balkans and you spend good deal of
your last what 15 years more than 15
years engaged in political economic and
other upheavals in this part of the
world we are studying and are
interesting in particular the the kind
of the religious side of the conflict
that broke out in what some describe is
former Yugoslavia can you speak to that
just in general what was the role of
religion it ranges in the discussions
all the way to religious religions play
no role they were just proxy for
something else all the way to religions
were the main cause of the conflict
while the resurgence in religion in the
post communist world must be seen in the
context because it has a certain
regressive and reactionary nature to it
under communism religion of course was
seen as an obscure attest read
scientific outdated worldview and value
system wherever communists came to power
we all know they claim monopoly not only
on power but also on truth so religion
was basically written off and the
expectation was that in that future call
it perfect society there would be it
would be not only a clusters but also a
religion a society and then we know what
happened in 1989 and following that with
the demise and dismantling of one-party
totalitarian regimes and now whatever
was suppressed including ethnicity in
multi-ethnic states especially in the
Socialist Federation like Soviet Union
and Yugoslavia whatever was suppressed
exploded religion and ethnicity so you
have a resurgence of of religion as a
constitutive
part of the national identity and along
with that especially in the new nation
building processes you have certain
ethnologist homogenize Asian taking
place and political leaders although we
had supposedly the arrival of democracy
political leaders recognize the power of
the religious sentiments and they
started manipulating Viet religious
sentiments of the nations and when when
when nations are in transition and when
nations in crisis and there are multiple
crises including economic the whole
question of identity the whole
uncertainty about the future and of
course the church or let me be more
precise religious communities whether
it's Islamic Orthodox Christian churches
and the Catholic Church is wanted their
power back their property and so on so
they became a partner with political
rulers of day of these new nations but
they here even now as as you I think
very helpfully contextualizing and
describing what's going on it almost
looks like it's a question of kind of
national identity and of power how about
the religious convictions themselves how
about religious sensibilities of the
people on the ground the board did they
play a significant role or were they
simply instrumentalized in order to
achieve certain so what were the
resonance is very small percentage of
the population in these nations was
truly committed to the core of their
religious faith and practicing it but
now in this euphoria everybody it
becomes religious more politically then
spiritually that's why you don't have
strong moral convictions here either
and the religion is kind of a cultural
resource providing persons with identity
around which
gather but not really a shaper of the
way in which one lives and understand
that's that's a good way to put it
communist ideology singular has now been
replaced by conflicting national
ideologies undergirded by their national
faiths and there were elements in in say
Orthodox Serbian Orthodox religiosity
which functioned over the centuries
precisely as such cultural resource that
were kind of dmort from the larger moral
context for instance there was a talk
about heavenly Serbia right there was
also kind of mythologized understanding
of religious conceptions could you could
you speak to the role that that mattered
and just let me first of all say that
true spirituality when it comes to
orthodoxy has been preserved through the
centuries in the monastery and that was
in detachment away from the realities of
this worldly kingdoms
now this sacral ization of political and
ethnic entities the language of course
says it was a sac realization so you
have a heavenly Serbia or you have the
language of the holy Russia for
centuries and it has been resurrected
again and you know that reminds you of
holy Crusades and Holy Inquisition like
God and the crow that's right exactly
exactly and so you have national
national gods you have tribal deities
and these these gods go at war go go to
war against each other and the political
leaders who have sea Commission's to
enlarge their territories or cleanse
their territories from the others from
those who are different of a different
fate these political leaders with their
sea conditions now abuse instrumentalize
the religious
sentiments and you have massive abuse of
religious language religious symbols to
the point where the weapons that will
kill the enemy that will kill the other
are being blessed by religious leaders
and how about the question of religious
sites in many parts of the world that
the existence of religious sites and
tying of religious religious convictions
to particular locales plays plays a
significant role and when there is a
threat of loss of connection with those
understandably maybe religious people
want to preserve that which is sacred to
them in both the orthodoxy Eastern
Orthodoxy various national Orthodox
churches as well as in the Catholic
Church you have a strong tradition of
folk religiosity and within the folk
religiosity as a mass movement
pilgrimages play a very important role
and you have these large numbers
millions of Polish people for example
pilgrim into the Black Madonna of chance
to hava which played a very important
role in the 80s as solid Arnage became
the first announcer of democracy and
especially with the Polish Pope with
John Paul the second now in in the
Balkans the history goes further back
the case in point our holy places
monasteries great historic treasures in
Kosovo that are so important to Serbian
history and Serbian Serbian identity no
wonder the Serbs consider Kosovo their
Jerusalem and even that language speaks
volumes so you have the heavenly Serbia
concept and you have the mission of the
leadership of that country to restore
historic sites and draw upon the them as
an inspiration for national liberation
and for for shaping their new identity
as a new nation state that is trying to
recover its historic greatness of course
there's a lot of Mythology there but we
don't have time to go into it shift
shift so to speak to the other side to
the Muslims with whom Albanian Muslims
Albanians are not exclusively Muslim
there are also some Catholic Albanians
and some more today and some Orthodox
and to the later war in Bosnia that
which is bossy acts who are
predominantly and defined as Muslims for
the most part this Muslims were at least
Bosniaks were pretty thoroughly
secularized so were the Albanians say in
Kosovo I know kosovo better than all
being itself although I have looked at
that phenomenon visited a number of
times one has to see that these Muslims
in the Balkans are not immigrants like
you find in UK or in France they are a
remnant so to say from the Turkish
Ottoman rule of the Balkans which lasted
anywhere between four and five hundred
years depending at what part of the
Balkans you look at and you had
convergence to Islam for economic
reasons in in in in in the Middle Ages
but but you were right and I guess the
secularizing process imposed by
communist regimes contributed that they
were nominal Muslims they were not
fundamentalist Islamic militants they
were not a threat to Christian Western
civilization or to Europe like Serbian
propaganda tried to make it look like
now it's it's a different picture what
is taking place right now but that's
also partly a function of the conflict
right so it's so we have a situation
where it's not so much that religion on
this Muslim side that is a cause of
conflict but you have a violent religion
that is caused by the conflicting
situation almost put yourself in the
shoes of Bosniaks okay nominal cultural
Muslims there is an aggression against
them first of all from the Serbian sides
and the Serbian military and
paramilitaries come in an almost
medieval fashion with a cross in one
hand and a sword in another ethnic
cleansing takes place mass rapes
horrible barbarities and so here is
supposedly a Christian nation trying to
eliminate Muslims from that part of
Balkans where they are a majority okay
when Croat seeing across the catholics
serves Orthodox when Croat see that
nobody stops the Serbian aggression
there are now Croatian leaders who say
well we are 17 18 percent of the
population why don't we grab some land
and they come not in the same fashion
but with religious slogans and abusing
religion and they fight the Muslims
you're talking about Bosnia I am talking
about Bosnia Bosnia which was which
suffered most of any of these nations
actually of any nations in the post
second war Europe now these Bosnian
Muslims are saying the only help we can
receive is because Europe is not doing
anything us didn't do anything for
several years and it almost looked like
there was there was an international
conspiracy against them so they are
looking for help to the Islamic nations
and they receiving some help and arms
have smuggled in although there is an
arms embargo and Mujahideen volunteers
are coming in large numbers and they
commit atrocities and then religious
teachers follow and say to the Bosnian
Muslims you are not real Muslims you
need to convert you need to read Quran
you need to drop eating these foods and
drinking these drinks and so on and so
there is a real Amoz ation taking place
right now the
you to the fact that they had the
perception that they were threatened by
the call it again Christian nations
that's a fascinating fascinating
reversal from what some people might
might expect so that you have
radicalization of and recycle ization
now in a different sense officer that
would have been worse had us-led NATO
force not coming because Clinton's
government said and Madeleine Albright
played a very important role here date
an agreement and whatever followed after
ninety five in a three-year delay we
must say that Clinton's administration
said we will not put our forces on the
ground unless the Mujahideen sleeve once
they are out of Bosnia we will come to
secure peace or at least to secure the
cessation of hostilities interestingly
several hundreds of these Muslim
religious teachers and Mujahideen's then
married Bosnia girls so they became
legitimate citizens now what given given
this kind of a function of religion as a
cultural resource primarily and
political resources that's right but but
then in a different case in with Muslims
as as right retrieval of religion as
power base what what can one do in
situations of this sort to to counter
what obviously is misuse of religion
nobody has in these oh very few in these
situations have looked at the teachings
of the religion and a larger worldview
of those those religion in ask well how
does it fit what we are doing right now
with those right they're reacting using
religion from below and from above as a
particular kind of resource what's the
consequence that we should draw from
this well several things one the church
and state separation the
it is defined in the USA it seems to be
is to be is the best is the best model
although there you have a separation of
religious communities constitutionally
functionally religious leaders are
political partners with those who hold
elected positions secondly in terms of
Education we need I know I know this is
a I may be misunderstood because I'm a
Christian minister I'm a theologian but
I'm pleading for for secularization I'm
not saying secularism as a new imposing
world view but secularization is a
methodological principle so that
individuals and communities will not be
enslaved to the myths of the past or the
distorted view of their religiosity so
in a sense a critique of religion no
definitely has to take take place and
then the kind of separation of religion
secularization its original sense of
separation of religion or
differentiation of society in various
spheres which means political and
religious are not identical and
overlapping but they are distinct traits
secularization in that secularization in
that sense but secularization also as a
liberation of the people so that they
will believe with their own minds and
their own hearts and not be manipulated
by either religious or political leaders
so that they will read their sacred
scriptures on their own and and and have
a kind of a hermeneutic that will
discover the other side of their
religion because when you have war when
you have violence when you have abuse of
religion for political purposes their
scriptures whether it's the holy
scriptures of the Christian faith or the
Holy Koran of the Islamic faith are read
selectively they are not interpreted in
their totality and you can in both the
Hebrew Scriptures in the Christian New
Testament as well as in the Holy Quran
you can find passages to support almost
anything if you plug them out of your
own context and the people who who have
not been taught are now mobilised to use
this discovery of this one segment of
their religiosity is to say defend their
very existence or to shape their future
along be more more militant more triumph
allistic more Selfridge righteous lines
I mean this is a question of a global
challenge with the resurgence of Islam
and even resurgence of Hinduism today in
the world so it's in a sense it's a
secularization a sense of not not a
denial of religion in the name of
irreligious and non-religious positions
but rather something like a certain
critique of religion in the name of its
authentic expression so it's a kind of
reformation yes yes going to the core of
your own faith discovering what is truly
precious and important in your faith if
if my faith demands my commitment then
it must be worded of my commitment and
then it deserves that I look at it
carefully what does it really teach so
there is a need for a kind of a
self-critical assessment of the way
religion is perceived and used and even
thought this is another factor religion
is now being taught in public schools
somebody needs to review those textbooks
what do those textbooks and our
textbooks generally about history say
about the other what do the bosniak
textbooks say about Serbs what do the
serbian orthodox teachers say about
Turks about Muslims and so on this this
this is a major challenge we need a more
much more rational approach to the 2d to
the role of religion in public life in
these nations right so once we have once
once religion is
separated from reason once reason is
returned its proper place within
religiosity and once one has returned
back to sources do you think the
religions can have a positive
contribution to make for peace even
though these religions may be even as
such at odds with one another right it
may disagree they may have exclusive
claims for do you think they present as
such a resource in a multi-ethnic
logical state if we understand the
nature of the pluralist society if we
show respect for human rights of all
communities and especially minorities
and if we value a religious liberty
there is no other way to go but develop
work and we have to be intentional about
that through education through media to
the kind of culture we foster through
public dialogues to critical
self-examination to mute through
processes of mutual accountability we
have to work on creating a climate where
everybody has the right to believe
believe even wrongly as long as it does
not cause pain or inflict pain or cause
aggression against those who believe
differently or those who don't believe
it all let me just say as a member of
the Helsinki Committee for human rights
in the region I feel that today we have
to defend the rights of atheists the
atheists are an endangered species
because the former communists have
massively made an exodus from their
dialectical materialism and they're in
the churches and now you have former
communist officials they want to have
pictures taken with the bishops they sit
in the first row for the national
religious celebrations and NN festivals
and the very religious people were
marginalized and treated the second-rate
citizens and at times even in
discriminated against or even persecuted
like our pair
where now you have the atheist
considered to be the dangerous ones
because now if you are a Serb you have
to be Orthodox if you are buzzing it you
have to be Muslim if your Croat or
[ __ ] you have to be Catholic if your
anything else
you are traitor you're you are you are
foreign intrusion you are threat to the
national religious cultural identity
identity is the big war big word and so
we live as you know in other parts of
the world we live in a war in the owner
world of warring identities and religion
must be critically re-examined and its
role in public life demythologized
so that we participate as citizens not
being forced to hide our religious
convictions but not imposing them either
and on this challenge note of issuing a
challenge and also a note of hope let us
end our interview and let me express my
deep gratitude for taking the time thank
you for inviting me